depuis le 13 octobre dernier la campagne
de vaccination contre la grippe a débuté
dans les pharmacies une année
particulière compte tenu des
circonstances sanitaires il ya beaucoup
plus de demandes que d'habitude on a des
plages horaires qui sont
très rempli rapidement pour privilégier
les personnes qui ont des pathologies
chroniques des personnes de plus de 65
ans pour avoir du mal à à proposer les
vaccins les personnes qui n'ont pas de
pathologies chroniques pour peur de
rupture de stock en fait dans cette
pharmacie de montigny le bretonneux
l'équivalent d'un mois de ventes de
vaccins des autres années a été
distribué la première semaine
pourtant il est uniquement donner aux
personnes à risque
nous on a eu des consignes claires du de
la part des agences régionales de santé
nous demandant de prioriser la
vaccination sur les personnes qui
étaient sur les populations à risque
donc les personnes pour lesquelles la la
sécurité sociale a envoyé un bon de
vaccination
contrairement aux autres années où on
est obligé de sensibilité les les
personnes à l'importance de la
vaccination grippale
cette année c'était plutôt le contraire
on devait freiner les les personnes qui
se ruaient en pharmacie pour acheter des
quantités importantes de vaccins les
soignants appelle à ne pas sous-estimer
l'épidémie grippale et déplorent ne pas
pouvoir vacciner tout le monde
pour moi c'est nécessaire de se vacciner
parce que la grippe saisonnière tue on a
dû refuser le refuser les ventes de ce
vaccin ou à la population normale qui
souhaitaient se vacciner et je rappelle
que la vaccination est importante
également pour
les personnes qui sont pas forcément
fragile seulement deux semaines après le
début de la campagne 70 à 80% des
pharmacies non plus de stock
elles attendent les prochaines
livraisons prévues pour début novembre